you know somewhere i read that you say
there are three levels of uh
uh brotherhood uh blood brothers
brothers in humanity and brothers in
faith
so tell us a little more about it that's
interesting you asked me that shay
i was uh speaking to an individual the
other day and
we were talking and i called him i said
hermano hermano
meaning like brother in spanish he was
like why are you calling me brother
you know i don't think he he was uh he
was getting it
uh he said you're not my brother and i
said hold on and i broke this down to
him i said look there's three types of
brothers
you have brothers now who are blood
brothers
right they come from the same womb then
you also have
brothers in humanity because we all have
if you look back we all have the same
father adam
so if you connect our lineage there
we'll be brothers in humanity and then
you have brothers
in faith those who believe as jesus
is moses abraham and the last and final
messenger prophet muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him
and that message that's all for all of
humanity of that pure monotheism if you
believe in that
worshiping the creation of the creation
then you have those brothers in faith
like me and you are
does that make sense well did it make
sense to him
then they had him thinking i had him
thinking yes
okay so so some some some explanation
yeah uh allow people to think a little
more about that
so yeah well i'm a
part of two of those brothers category
brothers in humanity and brother in
faith
uh how many blood brothers do you have
oh blood brothers i got uh one one
yes okay all right yeah so
you know you have this amazing life uh
i didn't know until this morning when i
started preparing for the show
that you have been in jail i would make
a correction i wouldn't because there's
a difference between like someone going
to a penitentiary
and someone getting in a few fights and
then you know sitting in the uh
you know county jail or something so uh
jail as far as going down and serving
time no that's
i i wasn't in like a penitentiary but
did i get in my time
you know and jahalia and some you know
fights here and there
and that's what had me really take it to
the next level to say okay if i have
this energy
right to want to fight the zeal let me
do it something positive so that's when
i started teaching martial arts
well before we come to that but how much
time did you spend
uh in in lock up or whatever it is
well i mean okay so usually what what
happens is you end up uh
you get into you're growing up in
chicago
right and in chicago you're if you don't
have proper
direction you're going to go in the
wrong direction so you get with the
wrong company you get with the wrong
crowd
so now this crowd you know is doing
certain things there on the street
and on the street is where all the
action happens so now
you got and and this is never remember
this is like
if you look um you have people who are
in this scene and they're also expecting
the same
right so now you come across someone
who's
at that age you know they're in another
crew
or they're in another uh opposing let's
say
uh uh crew let's call that
and they don't like you because you know
because you're not with us you're with
them whatever this pain is scenario
so then you guys you know start fighting
and then you end up police come and then
they end up
putting you in the lock up you know
overnight the next day
and then you're out again then you go
back and you think okay
so now you got some street credits as
they call it right so now you got
something to brag about and this is how
this is how the rotation happens now
people
respect you more oh you're the i don't
know if you ever seen these
movies that you know a lot of the people
like like goodfellas
scarface godfather have you ever seen
any of those movies cher
well i my office was in the area where
the
people will take tourist buses to look
for
a mob facilities in downtown chicago
okay aware of the language uh that
uh you know al-kapoom's never heard
uh you know brother muhammad ali on
one of the uh facilities at the house of
el capon
and and close by indiana so i've been to
that so i have some idea
so you have like by you over there you
have like taylor street that's a big
street right there you heard it
that's a very popular area where you had
a lot of the mafiosos and
and that hang out there but it's
unfortunate even to this day
many people respect people like that you
know the people you know they watch the
movies and they think okay man these
guys are like you know
the the last of the mohicans these are
the people that you know a lot of people
they
they they glamorize this kind of
lifestyle and i was i was a victim of
that also because what you see on tv
and you know the images that are
portrayed for for a young person you
think okay you aspire
to to try to you gravitate towards a lot
of these things
power respect and all the other things
that come with that so yeah to answer
your question
you know you would fight you end up in
jail you know
uh but thank god alhamdulillah that i
never ended up going to any penitentiary
or anything you know that's where you
have like a
you know uh a a a a long
serving of time a year two years and all
that but no i never went
so it was like look like a day it would
it would be
a day a month a couple months you know
a few months so but but that did give
you some time to think
yeah that's that's that's the thing when
you are
in the solitary confinement that or or
when you're isolated from the world
let's call that
when you're isolated from the world and
now it's you're in a jail cell and that
freedom is taken away from you
it should have you thinking it had me
thinking you know
but it's unfortunate that then people
they think one way
but then they get back out and some make
a change and and
uh some don't but definitely when your
freedoms are taken away
you wish to get back out and kiss the
ground and now you're crying from
from deep inside your heart you know oh
oh god help me help me help me get out
of here that's when your connection gets
stronger
right and uh this is uh
something i got to experience so so when
you were in this uh in some type of
gangs
um what did anybody knew that you're a
muslim
not well from the point of um
because my parents really weren't
practicing islam so you know the former
and you you kind of know the bosnian
community also you did a lot of
alhamdulillah miller rewards you for all
the work you did during the
genocide that was taking place in bosnia
so you kind of know it's a wonderful
community in that
but you had communism that had taken
over for was there for quite some time
uh so people had kind of went off from
the dean but many hamdulillah they ended
up coming back
held on to the dean some
uh would only participate when ramadan
would come around
you know but in bosnia if you were to
say to someone look
uh because many are very very proud to
be muslim and but they might not be
praying five times a day or fasting or
anything but if you tell them hey
you know you you uh say mention anything
oh this is not you know
uh criticize them or you're not a muslim
like this anything like that they'll cut
they'll come at you very hard you know
so so uh my my parents really weren't
practicing at that time
allah now they are alhamdulillah so
we we were just kind of you know doing
what everybody else does and i was
but i still would identify as being a
muslim i didn't eat pork
i could you know some basic things that
i knew that i didn't do my
my grandparents you know my grandfather
you remember and my uncle who
uh yeah do you remember my i know you
know hashim
uh dr khan who was the
leader of the bosnian community i worked
with him against to stop genocide in
bosnia yeah do you remember his uh my
grandfather
honorable father yeah well that's when i
used to go
my parents would send me to be with them
that i got
i used to learn some small surahs
i used to uh play like i was the modern
they had a house there and buff
in buffalo and i would spend time with
them they were practicing
praying five times a day everything and
then i would um
be with them for a month two months and
and i would just
you know it was uh they had some stairs
going up i would remember i would dress
up you know
i'd make their van as a young kid but
then i'd come home
so i would be praying but then i'd come
home no one's praying and i'd be praying
by myself but then it would wear off
and i forget about it
yeah so lost and found huh
[Laughter]
i even i even i even remember do you
remember rey seric
oh yeah he was my uh in northbrook
i would go there every sunday they would
have
it's like the sunday school so i would
go there and i had some
as a young child we would go there to
some classes he was one of my first
teachers
so how come you know you you had some
basic
knowledge training salaat and you're
calling people to prayer as a young
person
but in chicago then then so so it
do you think the absence of a good
company
uh allows a person who has been to
weekend school move away
100 company is a huge one is
huge and then i mean it's one thing just
going through the motions but not
understanding the essence the meaning so
there's a big difference between knowing
okay
i'm saying certain things in arabic
right
but i'm not understanding the essence of
it you know but there's a feeling there
for it it's gravitating i'm enjoying the
prayer
i'm i remember those are those are
moments certain moments highlights in
your life i remember those spending time
with my
with my grandparents and them teaching
me some of the some of the um
some of the quran i remember that yeah
but
uh bad company 100 this is what i think
one of the main things not having the
proper company
um and not being established in the
house in the home
so you have another term uh from muslims
who are proud muslims
but sort of lost in terms of following
the teachings
of god almighty and prophet muhammad
peace be upon him
so he called them muslims on batteries
where did you come up with that
[Laughter]
i must have heard it somewhere yeah
it's kind of like like you have the term
we have those terms that people use
ramadan muslims
then i think this is a bosnian term uh
music this is like you know
uh so you get this uh like the energizer
bunny you get this going going and then
it just goes away where's it at but we
know islam is something you do 24 7.
it's not just for ramadan it's not just
when you're in trouble or on sundays as
some people just do on fridays
it's every day yeah it's a way of life
all right so when you came out
of uh you know in and out of the
detentions uh and had to have
time to think when you came out how did
you connect back
because parents were still there company
probably the old friend the gang members
still wanted you back you know what's uh
and i think about this i think about
this uh
you know you have like omar dillahun and
the sahaba at that time
and and we can never compare to who they
were and what not but you had people who
were honorable
and allah guided them to the deen right
but then you have those who are just
even even being who they were they were
unarmed honorable and allah didn't guide
them
uh so there was a khalid walid and
people like this you know they didn't
believe at first you can call them they
were islam haters but later they came
uh even even uh when they did certain
things they did things with some kind of
honor code
and i was thinking back because i want
to i want to paint a picture that
you know i was the type and i picked
this up for my father if i gave my word
to something i got there for my father
he was a person of his word he never
stole he never cheated he didn't do any
of these
these things even though he wasn't now
he was trying he was a pr he was a good
honest
uh person he passed those things down to
me
i didn't even at that time like
gossiping or backbiting right
even at that time i was a person that
look if i had something with you it'd be
in your face if i told you i'd be here i
would be here
we'll take care of things uh so those
are the type of people like if i was
if i would get into a fist fight and
altercation
it will it was with someone that you'd
probably want to knock out yourself
and and and people uh also who who'd
wish to
you know want us smack someone around
because this person was a vile person it
was a person who was just in their
behavior they might have ripped a lot of
people off they were
but now they came across someone like me
who didn't let that stuff slide
you understand do you understand my
point so so it wasn't where you're
fighting some
innocent you know uh uh person on the
street
it was someone who was who was in that
lifestyle also right
so i want to make that distinction
somebody who probably you'd want to
knock out also
if you had watching muslim network tv
and this is who doesn't know any martial
arts
but i'm talking with the eddie
rajovic i'm trying to have it right
um right zoe tell me
uh did your were your parents the one
who came to america first
yeah they came about 40 some years ago
my mother came and then my
father yes okay so did they tell you
about anything about bosnia or you came
to know about bosnia later
no i used to travel i used to travel as
a as a child they used to take me to
bosnia
and i used to go regularly
yeah before the war okay and then after
the war i actually went over there and
spent
a couple years i lived over there well
you lived there as
an adult or as a child as an adult oh
okay yeah
so tell us a little bit about as a p as
a as a as a peacemaker
okay so tell us a little bit about what
are your memories of
uh living there because there were serbs
and crowds probably
as well yeah you know what i mean by as
a peacemaker
you know what i'm talking about i worked
uh with the
s4 i4 or s4 it was stabilization force
and they had uh
americans going over there to work after
the war so i was there for but my
experience
when i went that time i real i i was
just it was just uh when you got there
you landed you saw
pretty much most of the things just
blown up before that
before as my child had great memories
it's a beautiful
beautiful country it's an amazing
country uh
amazing history and i'd like to point
out for
for many of the not yet muslims out
there i always make this
and when i got deeper into the history
my uncle would tell me about this and i
then when i went i filmed a few episodes
with some historians uh so i tell people
because it's in the heart of europe
you had one of the greatest number of
actually unitarian christians
so our our roots the bosniaks the
bosnians you can look back
and you can connect and i give this
example so people who are also there who
are looking at you know
some islam is something you know maybe
weird foreign they can't connect with
but many people when islam when they got
to understand the teachings of it what
it taught like these
bosnians at that time who didn't worship
jesus they didn't worship any creation
they would pray outside the church they
were worshippers of one god one and only
one god so when islam came to him
some reports they say that over 60 000
people at one time
accepted islam so we were we were those
uh
unitarian christians who only worshiped
one god but then accepted the final
messenger prophet muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him and this is
that rich history in bosnia that you
find out so it's a beautiful
wonderful country and when i was there
they they they
opened up a line from london to
sarajevo and islam channel was doing
that uh
they were promoting that line i think it
was fl with fly bosnia so i really
recommend that people
they start to go when when they're able
to and then things open up to go and if
you're in europe anywhere you got to
stop in bosnia it's a lot of rich
history
and it's a beautiful country beautiful
people uh
great food and um you can go down here
to adan in sarajevo
praying nice and loud it's a lot of
history definitely put on your list to
do things
well this is one country i always wanted
to go but
anytime i checked up the price headline
it was very costly for me
because i worked i mean actually i have
so much that the president
of bosnia sent me a thank you letter
although
i didn't know who told him what i was
doing here but i was chair of the bosnia
task force
and we were very critical but were you
part of
the united states armed forces when you
went there
yes right alongside yes me and my father
well both of you yeah all right so your
father
so it was during that time your father
turned towards islam
also practicing he around that time and
then he started to he went to hajj
um i don't know exactly what year but he
started to
you know come back towards the dean but
then he just needed a little bit more
direction he just needed a little bit
more it was it wasn't like you know
because islam is structured it's like
there's
the five pillars you know you pray at
certain times you know you fast during
the month of ramadan not outside the
month remember that
so then uh alhamdulillah allah guided me
and i started to uh implement you know
the the five daily prayers started to
grow this was this was
what was very important was the
knowledge that's really what
and it goes back to what you're saying
earlier good companionship and then
really knowing because
this deen islam is based on evidence and
proof and it's it's something that
captivates not just the emotions in the
heart but the mind
so it had all the questions to what the
purpose of life is you know at that time
i wanted to look at other religions also
so i looked at all that did a
comparative study
and islam just stood out from everything
else and i gravitated to it and started
to
to implement it and then i started to
just naturally it wasn't something that
someone told me
but i just started to you know share all
the things that were
inspiring me motivating me lectures
talks
i would just sit the family down and say
come let's watch this
and i was just really you know um
excited about sharing and then
alhamdulillah they they started to
slowly you know
implement the five daily prayers we
started do that and
and from there alhamdulillah things just
started getting better
there were some struggles here and there
it's not always an easy ride but
alhamdulillah so how is uh how is bosnia
and bosnian community doing right now
in in bosnia right now before before i
i left i mean when was the last time you
visited
i believe a year ago i think it's a year
before all this
happened before this the lockdowns and
everything i was there i went with my
father
a couple times in the last few years we
went together
and i really i just i enjoy it's
such a beautiful country um beautiful
people
and uh great community there i mean you
you have uh you have i i think that
i i did a program um and i think they
because they had turned down a little
bit down
at one point when i was going during the
uh right after the the war the genocide
there
i remember going to sarajevo and you can
hear the adan really
nice clear and and then
you we were going there last time and
i think um they toned it down a little
bit asking people why why is this
but you can hear the church bells and
they've got nothing i'm not could i mean
you can hear them nice and loud that's
why it's so diverse
there you have like 500 plus churches
during the war that didn't get touched
you know islam preserved them uh
and then but people my point what i'm
trying to make is you have some people
again
not confident in to appease
other people and whatnot they started to
just like mo becomes muhammad
right aisha becomes
ace whatever the case and then muslims
start turning down as that and they
start you know
forgetting about sharing the message
educating the people so i was just
trying to create this you know awareness
when you come into begos jamia you have
you been to turkey shay
yes you know when you go to the blue
mosque did you see like you you guys do
this a lot with sound vision
education is so important and you have
flyers and
you know what is islam and other things
about muslims when you walk in the blue
mosque i'm making this example on the on
the right you can see all of the
different
posters and you have so many tourists
that come through there
uh there was one mosque that i was
trying to encourage them and i did
videos where you come in it's the main
masjid there in bosnia
that they would put up and have an
educational center and educate people
you know it's a beautiful
um opportunity because i think some
would got timid and just
worried about oh what the tourists what
people will say but
people are hungry when i talk to many of
the tourists and other people there and
whatnot
uh that's part of uh uh learning the
other culture
learning people learning about the
history and the dean islam is a great
is is actually the one of the roots of
that history there so you can't forget
that exclude that out
so one of the things which you just
mentioned that there are
500 churches in sarajevo and not a
single
church was uh attacked by
any muslim in sarajevo um
i mean that is i believe outside outside
i believe
the numbers out in bosnia or the total
number of churches
in bosnia are about 500. i'm i'm i don't
i don't
don't quote me on that i don't know if
it's sarah or the number that when i it
was
500 churches i i believe that's in in
the bosnian area
it might be just i'm not sure but that's
the number there's some mosques which
were destroyed
oh you had a ton of moss i mean just the
majority were just you know obliterated
they were just
demolished to the ground just destroyed
i mean bulldozed
uh blown up muslims talk about normally
about
their history that protection of
churches and other religions
as you know that the uh the key
uh to bethlehem major church
is still preserved uh by muslim and a
muslim family
i think there will be a great
documentary if people
go through the churches that no church
was destroyed
whatever the number is and then show
some of the
mosque and all that so i think that
itself is a documentary don't you think
oh absolutely yeah and this is a great
example of it being
uh the teachings of islam right there in
bars in the heart of europe i mean
something as a reference that you can
point and say look this is pointing out
that
the church bells rings full out but the
muslims have turned down the volume of
adam from the lord speakers
and you think it is not i mean this is
not to keep people
you know people who are sleeping in the
morning not to wake them up
uh it's not a courtesy but more it's a
fear of something
i what i and i mean you can go to a and
i
i talked to the people the community
there so i wanted to hear what they had
to say right and i did an episode you
can
check it out on our on our channel it's
called uh thumbs up or thumbs down so i
asked the people i ask your mom shakes
people there
and i get to so because i don't live
there what right do i have now
you know to come in and and you know try
to tell people what to do but i wanted
to hear what the people's voices were so
i talked to
tourists and i talked to the muslims
non-muslims and it was amazing
when the adan would go off i talked to
many of the tourists they say they like
it you know one compared it to like when
he would go to turkey and hear hear the
adam there
it's something different unique liam
neeson when he would hear that
i don't know if you remember that one
that report back then
at first it was annoying in the morning
but then it turned out
reports say that it was the most
beautiful thing coming out of his mouth
he was saying that when he would hear
the
at one point he was contemplating even
accepting islam
so i would ask and try to understand
why why was this so
there were many were saying because of
you know
some of the cafes that were around and
you know when they're down would go off
this would disturb some people and that
so you always have that conflict you
know you always have
you know uh these things um
that will disturb some but we know that
this is
part of the deen this is something that
is a dawah in and of itself it's
you know so so tell us about this uh
brazilian martial arts which you learn
did you started learning when you were a
gang member or it just started after
that
the uh i used to box i started off
boxing
i did some kickboxing and then a blend
of different martial arts
and then i tried this particular martial
art called gracie brazilian jiu jitsu
and i had a small guy who was probably
like his name was edson
he was probably around 140 give or take
and at that time i was really also into
working out
and i tried it out and i got really
tired
and i was in good shape but he was very
technical and i didn't know the
techniques there i didn't know the art
it was something new to me and then
it was on the ground and i was amazed
after he displayed how this worked and
he submitted me
and i was like turned on and then from
there i just took off with it i really
you know
uh started to spend i used to say if
there was
seven days in the week i would do eight
days just it was
constant training and this was this was
some
time um in the late 90s in the late 90s
i took off with it alhamdulillah and
many people who
have seen the ultimate fighting
championships they
would know the gracie family that's the
family who actually started
the ultimate fighting championship with
hois gracie
who was one of my first teachers and i
became the
uh first rep uh american rep
bosnian rep for this other part of the
family
here in america i used to travel also to
brazil and do training
out there so alhamdulillah yeah this is
uh
and this was something like i always
compare it you know
in in islam you have evidence it's
evidence-based
this this martial art is also
evidence-based when we say it's proven
the most effective martial art it's not
just by theory because what this family
did
way they said okay if you believe your
martial art is the best
let's just not talk in theory let's see
the science behind it so let's so they
developed this word let's go in a cage
and let's see what you got let's see
which martial art is going to be
dominant so they at that time they had
it was very exciting they had different
styles kung fu
karate taekwondo boxing and everybody
was fighting each other to see which one
is the
the best and this person who is gracie
he destroyed everybody he beat everybody
by taking getting into a clinch and then
taking them to the ground
and finishing them and it proved you
know that it was the most effective
martial art
that was out there and that's what
really captivated
me how many histories do you have uh
alhamdulillah we have a few hundred
students you know
in the hundreds and how
some of them graduated or they're still
your students
yeah so you have different belt system
and when you get to
a certain level you're still a student
i'm still a student i'm still learning
you know it's the tea the students are
teaching me meaning that as i teach
i'm picking up it's so much to learn uh
but
yeah so they get to a certain level and
then it just keeps going it's a
lifestyle you've made it a lifestyle now
so black belt and beyond you just keep
going it's a part of your life
in in the bosnians but i don't expect
that yeah but no you know i just say
rezvik reservation most people
redzevic graduate yeah yeah okay
now tell me uh how much time
goes in your martial art and how much
time you
put on your deen show well it's uh
the martial art is i trained a few times
a week
and i try to actually be because it's a
part of
living i believe a holistic and this is
a lifestyle
exercise is part of that this is
something they say that over 60
of the diseases you'll be able to fight
off just by incorporating exercises so
this is part of
exercise that we do so along with good
nutrition i've been taught i like
what's that that vegetable that you uh
that you
um orchid is it the one you turned me
out to
that you have in your garden yes i have
a lot of
vegetables but the garden has died out
now but
i still have there was a particular one
i never heard the
the vegetable that you were talking
about
oh i don't know which one i was talking
about we'll talk about your farm and
garden also but tell me
how much time on din show so that takes
up the majority of the time
most likely more than that but i try to
balance it out so
good training in the morning some
working out some jiu jitsu
also i teach and then and then from
there
you know we have scheduling guests you
know
working behind the scenes you know you
know everything that goes into running
the media so this would probably take up
more time but
uh we try to balance everything out so
we're not like uh like a car with uh one
deflated wheel when did you start uh
producing the danger
officially uh 2006 2006
i was planning to do my uh first hajj
and from there i had one one sheikh
sheikh muhammad and he was in town
and at that time i was also doing what i
was doing was i was trying to get some
some some because i started practicing
the dean probably earlier towards
2000 sometime and from there i started
to
figure out other ways i can get good
deeds so i used to bring out
you know different uh connect with
different shake and have different
sponsor a lecture or something a program
and i remember
i was at one point i don't know if you
remember dr amir ali
yes yeah i spent many many years there
also learning
there's one of my first teacher may
allah and
i was thinking of opening up a shop like
that a dawah center maybe like have a
coffee shop with some books
that people can come and and they can
learn but then
youtube started at that time and from
there
we were planning to go to hajj and i
thought this would make this inter you
know with hajj is a lot there's a lot of
steps
so i said let me record this so i don't
forget all the steps but at the same
time
why not be efficient with the time let's
put this out youtube have just started
so then we ended up recording it the
shaykh liked it
muhammad and from there that's when it
started i thought man this is a great
way to reach more people through the
media
then rather than just having a small
tawa center at our shop this is a great
way
that we can go ahead and share this
message because at that time
what motivated me was when you're
learning what islam is peace mercy
justice
all these things the opposite what the
media is pushing out
so i thought man who's i mean they're
they're they're misrepresenting
islam 100 is and we have to
do our part to get the right message out
so the media was a great
tool that was at our disposal and
alhamdulillah we
started using it and here we are how
many followers do you have on your
youtube
um i don't i don't know what happened
what is it like a few hundred thousand
but what happened was we started
uh we got we had another channel that we
were on and that channel
ended up getting shut down for a little
bit so that's then i branched out
because at youtube at that time only
allowed like 10 minutes
but then if you had if you were a
partner they allowed you the
hour so then we had another youtube
channel
that we were airing our stuff on
and we just used that channel we didn't
really officially have our own until a
few years ago
so we ended up going
and branching out and starting our own
channel which
we should have did earlier but
alhamdulillah things worked out how they
were that channel ended up coming back
up
but at that time when they shut it down
for i don't know uh
what reason what it was one of the
programs something we talked about i
don't remember exactly
and then alhamdulillah here we are now
now
a lot of satellite channels and they
they carry that
and probably your message is to a whole
lot of millions of people but
what which shows do you remember which
interviews you remember
to be your best
i don't particularly have i when i see
you now i
remember the important topics you know
that we discussed that really stand out
that
the um the plight of uh the muslims in
myanmar we spoke about that
uh those things when i see you now it
reminds me of that program we
we we did and it reminds me of the
the um horrific events that are
happening over there
and but we forget we go on with life and
many of us you know we forget about uh
and this is a great opportunity to
remind i mean how is that situation
there with them right now what's
what's you you were closely there you
know out of those three million
muslims from burma or myanmar
majorities just refugees sitting here
and there
without citizenship cannot go back
they want to go back to burma and
myanmar because that's where their
ancestral home
is and the sense is far away there is no
oil over there or maybe there is oil and
world doesn't need oil
whatever is this situation nobody seems
to be interested
in what they want to do they want to go
back their home
and live there comfortably then another
program
seeing you and to answer your question
another show that was uh
is um creating awareness uh of what
happened in china i did a program
not too long ago and just hearing of
what you just can't believe in this
modern day and age we're supposed to be
you know a civilized people but
um when you hear of you got almost over
2 million
people in these modern day inquisition
camps inquisition camps you know they
call them education camps so that
program i did
um trying to uh inshallah create some
awareness
i mean this is a very important program
to get some of it because people are
just not
in tune what's with what's happening and
um
you obviously how is the situation there
now with the with the chinese muslims
well you know when you say chinese
muslim there are chinese muslims also
who speak chinese language and
they are chinese culturally but they are
muslims
even they are in very much difficulty
now
but the people which we are talking
about your people
they are not chinese they are uber
muslims yeah
they they are ethnically different they
are linguistically different they are
religiously different
uh there are turkic people who china
occupied a while ago they are still in
the same shape
i mean china is building more
concentration camps
more oh yeah and they are forcing uh
a woman to um you know they're
israelizing women
they're forcing uh muslim women
to marry you know chinese
and which they don't like some of them
married to get their parents released
and then they commit suicide i mean it's
a horrible situation
and a lot of american companies actually
are complicit because
some of those people are you know
being used as a slave labor in america
major companies in america are using
and benefiting from their slave labor so
there are laws in the
congress which we are pushing uh but
president trump doesn't seems to
care for human rights but there are a
lot of those things which which
which require attendance so your shows
so
my show when i invited me was about
human rights of muslims
what other types of shows you have in
the deen show
so we get a lot of different people from
all walks of life
who might have been from a particular
religion background and then we
highlight their story
because people now think okay islam
muslim arab and all these other
stigma stereotypes but then when we show
an italian
muslim italian muslim polish muslim
italian german so we get stories and
then people are like
why did they accept islam submission to
the creator not the christian why what's
their story
and it's something that hopefully people
can uh relate to
the message that they found and they
found the evidence in it with the quran
and everything else that came
along with it hopefully people when they
see these stories which we do a lot of a
lot of those stories
[Music]
um you have
a mixture but the majority would be a
lot of a lot of convert stories reverse
stories however you want to call it
uh and then getting to know like the
million the billion dollar million
dollar question why so why did they
accept islam with all the hype and all
the
you know attacks that are thrown out
there against uh
islam and we become i like i still uh
use what you said one time we become uh
professional condemners that should be a
sixth pillar of islam
you said that right yeah i remember
doing the
condemning terrorism six times a day is
the sixth pillar of islam
yeah uh so from from there um
with the with the hopes that people can
can um see behind you know
all of the veils of deception through
some of these stories and then also we
talk about other relevant contemporary
issues that are going on like the uh i
had a school teacher brenda lipsack
you know who talks about you know the
hidden agenda or the not hidden the
outright agenda what's happening in the
schooling system with the children and
the kind of things that they're uh that
they're being taught
you know and and other guests
who have a message a good message to
sierra of positivity
of hope of light uh we interviews people
like that
you know some of you you mentioned to me
once that
some of your time goes on a farm in
indiana
tell me what is that farm life which you
have going on the site
this uh it's very nice i before i
couldn't imagine myself
getting out of the city but once i
started to really um
and i talk about this a lot just living
a holistic life what does that mean
that means that you know there's
different aspects you have
the one part that we work on like the
prophet muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him he talked about
there's a morsel of flesh in the body if
it's sound the whole body will be sound
so the heart now through prayer to you
know other people are meditating doing
other things we have salah five times a
day
we're connected to our creator and then
we have the the five pillars and we have
the quran and sunnah which is a complete
blueprint for life but it also doesn't
leave out nutrition
it doesn't it's a healthy balance right
getting out into nature you know and how
do you appreciate
the creator but through his creation so
you get out and you get away from the
what i call it the concrete jungle
and you get out there and you you see
the you know beautiful scenery and you
connect uh
you know uh in a way that in the city
it's
you're kind of uh like i said in a
concrete jungle so i really enjoy
just getting out and that's what i love
about about bosnia a lot this this has a
lot of these mountains and
farms and and things where we we've kind
of been just uh
i call it domesticated right we kind of
you don't see the stars
anymore you're in the city you don't i
remember being what's that is in
mina you remember that was the when you
look up and you see all the stars you
have to
you're sleeping outside and you're that
night
so when you get away from the city and
the smog and the pollution and you can
get out
you know you it kind of puts you more in
touch you know how things were kind of
meant
meant to be so i i enjoy that i really
do
so this farm you raise chickens
animals what do you do there
we get some uh sometimes we'll get some
sheep get some chickens
yeah and uh try to get that
try get some vegetables going yes yeah
i don't know what vegetable i i told you
but i do grow
quite a bit of garden here uh this year
it was not uh as high producing as other
time except cucumber ram and i had about
five six hundred cucumbers i must have
eaten
300 myself i was eating the morning
afternoon and evening and it was very
delicious
uh so you also promote uh
wholesome living so the faith the
exercise and the right
eating you know but some of the people
in this wholesome living are going again
against
science and against medicine and all of
those things
um how do you bring balance to your show
in this regard i love this is see these
are the kind of talks we need to have
you know islam is not against medicine
i mean and there's a difference between
drugs and medicine
so yeah some people take it to the
extreme you follow me
uh but then you also when you look um
into
any person that most people that i've
come across who live a healthy
wholesome or get you know life and i've
interviewed many of these people who've
been
let's say into nutrition or into
physical fitness for like 20 years
and i would ask them literally i say
when's the last time you've been to the
doctor
and the guy is looking he's thinking
he's like 20 years ago i said how does
someone not
end up going to the doctor i want to do
what he's doing
so those are those lifestyle hacks i
call them those things in life and and
one
just key thing is just eating real food
allah tells us in surah baqarah
it's clear um you know eat of the thai
bat
right the good wholesome food we have we
have halal also but
you can you know synonymous to that
would be what pure
organic good foods even though back in
the day there was no such term as
organic but now you got to put it was
just food
but today you have over a half a million
fake food items
and those are those foods in the center
of the grocery
stores you have one section i'll say
healthy food and the person says okay if
this is healthy food what's the rest of
it
it's fake food and fake food is the food
that comes with a list of ingredients
that you need a chemistry degree to
pronounce it's uh it's it's
it's filled with toxic chemicals things
that now uh majority of them do not
nourish your body the way with the fuel
that it needs and then you end up
having chronic inflammation you end up
feeding the cancers in your body and you
end up
becoming a statistic where one in fifty
percent uh
two of women and three of men or vice
versa end up
having contracting cancer one of the
leading causes have to do 95 percent
they say of
chronic disease is due to the food
choices that we make
so now if you end up doing everything
and this is part of tying the camel you
put good wholesome food in your body
nutritious food you give the boot the
body what it needs then you exercise
right and exercise can be speed walking
a little bit of jogging
20 minutes a day get the heart rate
pumping right get it
stress that body in that good way and
then also now getting good sleep
breathing good drinking good water
and if and in in the meantime i had one
doctor holistic doctor
doctor very intelligent bright um uh
doctor told me
that any time that uh the doc
they they feel she feels that she feels
any kind of um
um you know that itch you get in your
throat like you're about to get sick
you ever heard you know you ever get
that itch like you're about to get sick
the doc she says i take a clove of
garlic
and i uh uh swallow this
right you can chop it or whatever and
this knocks it out and i
this is this is medicine this is this is
this is whole
this is real medicine you have herbs you
have natural means out there
and this is one thing that i've been
doing this is uh some
you know people can try it it might work
for you it might not
or you can go to walgreens css and you
can get
something that's going to suppress this
and maybe it'll it'll suppress it for a
little bit it's like putting a bandage
on a
on a uh on a check engine light so
i have to give this example that a real
holistic doctor right if you come to him
and say look i have a pain in my foot
my foot is killing me i have a big pain
the doctor doesn't just prescribe you
the real doctor just ibuprofen and gets
rid of the pain
no he goes for the root cause so he's
going to go and get the rock out of the
out of the foot okay because over time
what's ibuprofen going to do
it's going to destroy your kidneys and
then you're going to be on kidney deli
dialysis you know it's a horrible
horrible
trade-off you follow me so there's a
difference between that drug it has its
place
right and then the natural means that
are out there
but but but then you have people who
don't don't care for that they just put
anything in your body my uncle would say
this dr kosovich he would say
he would say god didn't give you or make
your body a garbage can so stop putting
garbage in it
right so when we start honoring this
gift the vehicle of light that allah has
given us
right and we start using food as
medicine you know
like hippocrates this is they call him
the father father of medicine this is
where doctors take their hippocratic oh
they say let food he said let food be
your medicine and medicine be your food
you'll be amazed when you start studying
some of those vegetables in your garden
you know uh the things that they can do
for the body you follow me
so yeah there's some people who won't
you know take anything you know
of anything out that's you maybe go to
the extreme but then there's some smart
people who say hold on let me see the
side effects of that
let me see you know and sometimes the
side effects actually
end up being worse than what you're
dealing with you follow me
so we have to be balanced and islam
calls us to be balanced okay but we also
have to be
awakened to a lot of these things you
know not to be sheep and blindly just
take whatever is
you know we gotta question we gotta do
research we gotta think
well thank you so much my brother thank
you
you're welcome thank you eddie rodzovic
who is the uh host and the producer
of the dean show he's a martial art
expert and as you heard him he cares for
a wholesome
life